uh I I been talking about Christmas
about trees because there's always
something interesting to say about trees
at least once a year and so uh decided
to make this a December
tradition uh it's called the annual
Christmas tree lecture now now the title
today can you zoom in on this like we're
going to check the I want to check to
see if the uh camera operators awake yes
great okay so title today is trees
forest and polyomino now I I chose this
title uh actually uh some months ago and
uh but then two weeks ago I decided
completely to change this to change what
I'm going to talk about uh today so
actually you might call this threes
force and polyomino zero with the with
threes force and polyomino part one
coming up some other some other December
um now how many of you know what
polyomino are
there's a few okay now when I was a when
I was a college student
everybody knew um about
pentomino uh which are uh which I'll
show you in a minute but um but now
nowadays I think everybody knows about
tetrominos because how many have ever
played
Tetris okay here we got it okay so so um
uh I mean you know some aminos are
always are always in um popular in fact
here's the
here's a book about the uh the Great
Book on Pino second edition by uh by S
goam who's uh professor at USC all these
years and uh and can we zoom in on the
on one thing in the back here it's kind
of appropriate because we're getting
toward the year 2001 here's a uh
something from Arthur Clark he's saying
that um uh he Stanley cuber guy got
hooked on 12 small pieces of plastic uh
which starting as a geometrical problem
understandable by any child can r
rapidly escalated you have the sord of
Mind into a way of life it started
because the first version of 2001 David
rman was going to match his wits against
the computer hell not at chess but at a
game called
pentomino and so uh today what I want to
talk about is okay pentomino are things
like this that have five that that are
made out of five squares and and
tetrominos are you know the case of four
squares and uh uh and then there's
nominal which have n squares and this is
this is interesting for many many
reasons uh because it's a fundamental
thing whenever you work with like with
with with pixels with Graphics uh it's
uh because the definition of a polyomino
is it's anything that's that any set of
pixels that's connected Rook wise
connected words you uh you can get from
any one to to any of the other ones uh
just by moving horizontally vertically
um these these these women P um
pentomino uh there's beautiful sets of
of these things that you can buy I think
this comes from Kon Enterprises and uh
makes a nice key ring too but uh uh but
uh it's it's kind of it's kind of
addictive if you have a set of of all
the of all the 12 pental to to see if
you can put them together to make uh to
make certain patterns and I actually I
guess I mentioned that when I when I
talked about dancing links earlier this
year now um uh so there's there's lots
of actually connections between
polyomino and trees um and and that was
my original idea was talking about
certain kinds of polyenals that uh that
that you can understand uh by
understanding more about trees but um
but but uh then that as I say I changed
the whole idea is what I'm going to talk
about today is sort of more like what I
did during Thanksgiving weekend uh
because on Thanksgiving weekend I
started to write a program that would um
that would enumerate how many polyenals
there are um and um I I had I had an
idea on uh um that would you know that I
thought would would probably do it
pretty fast and so I looked on the web
and I found out that uh uh you know I I
knew the sequence for how how many there
are you know one nominal a monomino
there's only one and there's two dominal
well as there's one Domino but you can
tip it um and uh so I looked up the
sequence in uh the handbook of integer
sequences everyone knows that way of of
doing mathematical research nowadays you
can if you if you you're interested in
in something you want to find out if
every anybody's ever written a paper
about a certain sequence of numbers you
just type in the sequence and it and it
takes you to the literature and it takes
you also to the web pages so I found
this
man Olivier Silva in Portugal who had
pages about enumeration of of pentom of
polyomino and he and he had gone up to
28 uh last year with a with a uh about
three years of of computer time on on on
on on on on several dozen pentiums uh so
it only only lasted a couple of months
in total
um done in background job and so he had
he had U he had he had figured out how
many 28 aminos there are and it's some
huge number so um so I I thought my idea
I might be able to go further and then I
spent the next uh um the next two days
writing the program and the next three
days debugging it and uh and a week ago
and a week ago today I ran it uh in the
final glorious run and uh lo and behold
uh I found
the exact number of uh of 30 omino and
so I figured oh great I got a world
record he had only gone up to 28 I I got
not only I got 29 and 30 um and that's
where my method broke uh I'll tell you
more about that that method in a minute
um but uh that was uh that was a week
ago today now is Andrew Conway here yeah
ah great I got to talk to you after so
then on on Wednesday I went to the
library and looked up a paper by Andrew
Conway uh who had evaluated the 25
ominos uh 5 years ago um and I figured
okay he's probably done you know the
same method and you know it's just one
of these things but just to be complete
I'll look at his paper well turn on no
you know he had a great he had lots of
great ideas in that paper kind of
revolutionary new approach to the thing
and um and uh uh so uh not only that but
he he had a a method that that where he
could prove that his method was only
taken to get the nomino would only take
um squ > of 3 to the N power um in space
and time well my method empirically was
running like two to the N power so his
method had to be as ASM totically better
and I had to I had to I had to program
it so my next idea was so I spent all
all last Wednesday reading his paper
very carefully at midnight I finished on
on his stud I decided okay today I'll
talk about that I'll talk about
comparing his method to this other
method that I had and then we'll see uh
it's not it's not immediately clear
who's going to win when and is 30 I mean
asymptotically great but uh but when you
get up uh but but maybe it took took
takes a while before his method would
would start to shine um so um uh that
was last Wednesday last Thursday uh I
got a note from from the guy who has a
web page in Portugal and he said o Don
did you know that earlier this year
people in in in Australia had um had
evaluated up to n equals
46 46 on them oh my God you know so this
would mean that I had to go you know 16
more steps at at at root three to that
would be you know 3 to the E power more
in in space and time and I already was
using almost a a gigabyte of memory so
so uh um they obviously had had some
some more ideas too and I'm going to be
talking a little bit more about that uh
as as we go on that's a background for
for uh today's lecture I I I wanted to U
I wanted to tell you today what the
number of 47 ominos is but uh that'll
have to wait till tomorrow or or Friday
I'm still working on the program uh um
but um but now Andrew uh you it's at
your discretion whether you want to tell
the people in Australia the secrets that
I'm going to reveal today about how I'm
going to try to beat their record uh uh
uh uh but anyway they'll have a chance
to to to go up again if I do beat the
record so anyway this is a it's an area
that involves great mathematics and
great computer programming in the same
time and it also has to do with trees so
I'm glad to be talking about it today
first of all let's get started with
simple things um here are here are the
tetraminos if people play Tetris you
know that uh well there are really only
five five different shapes there's this
shape there's this L shape and it's you
know Mir image uh there's this T shape
and there's this sort of a z shape and
the square but then uh uh but then uh
the mirror image uh actually makes a
diff you know and when you're playing
Tetris the thing moves around so you
actually have 19 different possible uh
shapes now this turns out to be
mathematically the nicer problem the one
that has the more more more um uh you
know Simplicity to its uh it its
formulation uh this is the number of of
ways you can have a connected component
uh out of pixels and uh and then uh uh
if you if you're actually making a game
you can say well I can turn the piece
around or I can rotate it uh so then you
don't have to make so many pieces but um
uh in fact uh mathematically this is
this is the sort of nicest uh uh from
the theoretical point of view and then
you can also if you want find out how
many of these have symmetry and and you
know it's like like this one the L shape
has eight different different ways to
place it this T shape has has only four
because it has reflective symmetry this
Z shape has only four because it has a
rotational uh symmetry 180° rotation um
and this one has uh uh you know all
eight possible symmetries so there's
only one way to put this guy so so uh uh
you you can easily count how many have
symmetries because I if the Symmetry
like reflection you only have to go up
to half end and then the other half are
are determined so uh so it's much faster
to enumerate the symmetrical cases so so
anyway this is the some of the
background with tetrominos there's 19 of
these when you go to pentomino there are
there are 63 ways to do it U one of them
has has all the possible symmetries and
this one you know this one has four
symmetries cu there two ways and then
all of these things these are the ways
to to put the 12 pental but in their
various rotations and if you're placing
them down you really have to deal with
these 63 possible shapes okay so now
um uh let's see I got to get
my stuff here so
uh now I uh one way to enumerate them
for small n that's that's that's plenty
good is just to um uh to imagine uh that
you well um well you take your favorite
algorithm for for determining connected
connected component uh which is probably
depth first search uh so you uh if you
if you have a graph and you want to find
the connected component uh you um uh
incidentally there are people standing
in the back that makes me a little
nervous there's some there a couple of
empty seats in the front row why don't
you come up here and make yourself
comfortable and you yeah um so uh you
know you want to find all the connected
component of a graph you start at some
at some vertex of the graph and then you
uh and then uh uh you say does it have
any neighbors okay then I'll look at the
I I'll look at the neighbors um and then
um uh yeah we got we got three over
here um so we look at the neighbors and
uh uh and then uh they might have
neighbors that we haven't explored yet
and so you so you keep on uh uh uh uh
systematically if you're if you're at if
you're at a place you you you probe a
cell that you don't know if it's present
or not and uh and you move to it if it
isn't present so you could you can
formalize this in in various ways bread
for search death for search uh but uh
but it involves uh uh every once in a
while the the program will ask is the
cell occupied or not and if you know
it'll look at one of the neighbors going
to the left right uh up or down and uh
and and it'll get an answer yes or no
yes it's occupied no it's not and then
it'll continue on so if you just go
through uh uh this program and then you
uh and you and you imagine that there's
an oracle that gives answers yes or no
uh uh then you can systematically run
through all possible uh uh sequences
that this program will ever take and you
stop whenever you got to the end cells
and and uh so and you you'll you'll uh
that's one way to uh uh to get to uh uh
I mean actually the Oracle is going to
have it's going to have to you stop if
you get to n plus one because then you
know you've gone too far um or or at the
end it's going to have to give you a lot
of no answers in order to to to
terminate anyway that that that makes
sure that you hit every one of these uh
63 things exactly once however that
method is going to take you um uh as
many certainly as many steps as there as
there are different different different
of anomal you're going to you're going
to actually construct each one of these
if we're going to beat this method and
and get and and get to these other these
other cases where I think the the number
of 30 ominos was uh well I I didn't even
bring the number with me but it's it's
so huge that uh that that uh you know
it's much more than the number of um of
machine cycles that I used to compute it
uh so so that so certainly I had to have
a method that wasn't going to be hitting
every one of these guys um uh but
instead I had to have some some some
some faster way that I could be doing
many of them at once
um and uh and so I I played around with
uh with ideas in fact I was inspired by
by a comment in the first paper that was
it wasn't enumerating nominos but a
similar thing where where instead of
using Square cells you use he hexagonal
cells and uh guy named Fred Lon was
working with the atlas computer in the
60s and he's the first person to
evaluate uh anomos for for for large n i
I think he got up to only 17 or 18 but
that was large in those days for uh an
atlas computer was uh was uh considered
a really giant machine in the 60s um and
um uh used by the uh uh you know the
theoretical physicist in England um and
there was a comment in his paper that
when he enumerated these um these
polyhexes which are the things made out
of hexagons instead of squares uh uh
there was a a friend of his had checked
all his results for the case Nal 12 in
one afternoon no by hand without a
computer and uh this was some you know
but there was some 75,000 of them so I
figured there this you know there must
be some way to do it and and uh so so
that so I when I was swimming two weeks
ago I said hm maybe I can do it like
this and so I so I was going to I was
going to take a look at horizontal
slices through a uh through an
anomo uh and then I would I would say uh
you know if if I know uh I I would build
a slice by slice instead of instead of
cell by cell now uh one interesting
thing turned out uh uh to be to be true
right away that I found out that the
number of possible slices of an nomino
you take something with n cells and then
you and you cut it horizontally and you
look at at what you got uh the number
turns out to be exactly Fibonacci well
I'll write it down so horizontal
slices of an
nomino um it turn turn out to be exactly
FN + 1 - n + 4 when n is greater than or
equal 3 this is a Fibonacci number uh so
so the Fibonacci sequence came up
there's a number of possible things that
that that could occur this includes the
empty the empty slice uh if you if
you're cutting it way above or below um
the thing um and so for example what can
of pentomino there are seven possible
slices that you get out of these
pentomino now um
uh uh then I Then I then I asked myself
what about um uh
uh if I put one slice next to another
slice what what can you possibly get
there and and and let let's suppose I I
actually want it to be connected so so
what about
2xn u 2 by K andinos the ones that fit
in two
lines so so so this would be for example
well this guy would qualify uh
not not these here's one that fits in
two
lines and uh and you know so so how how
how many of these will this turned out
to be uh to be uh uh let's see where's
the where's my
formula
um okay wait a minute I got to have it
here number of fixed pinals here it is
TN - 2 plus TN TN 1 + t - 2 - 2 when n
is greater than or equal 2 well this is
the tribonacci sequence now the now the
now the tribonacci sequence is the sum
of you know F the Fibonacci sequence FN
is FN minus one plus FN minus 2 is the
sum of every number is the sum of the
previous two the tribonacci sequence is
equal to the sum of the previous three
guys it's a terrible name but anyway
that's what people that's what we call
it and and we start out uh in such a way
that the sequence starts actually one 1
2 4 7 uh so at the very beginning we
have to start out with 1 2 4 and then we
get seven um 13 and then three of these
is 24 and then 44 and so on and as I say
if you want to look up um the handbook
of inergy sequences on the web it'll
tell you everybody who's ever written
about the tribonacci numbers now this is
now the tribonacci numbers are the
number of of binary sequences where you
never have three ones in a row so all
sequences the zeros and ones where where
where you're not allowed to have three
ones in a row and this is the tribon
well it turns out that that uh uh you
can you can make a nice uh one to one
correspondence between all uh you know
U all all all such sequences of zeros
and ones with no three ones in a row uh
enumerated by TN minus1 and TN minus 2
um you can you can you can make a one to
one correspondence between that and all
the two 2 byk nominal there kind of a
beautiful way to map this into another
so that's well that was one evening's
Pleasant Recreation but I could see that
this is growing not these numbers is
growing like 1.6 to the N Fibonacci and
and the tribonacci numbers are are are
growing I forget what it is 1.8 to the
end something like that so these this
anyway U we're getting to U uh we're
getting polinomial growth but um what
about the the number of of of animals
the poly of of of polyomino um a lot of
different notations for it um and Andrew
uses um a as subn but uh I'm gonna use
David
carner's favorite notation T of then uh
and this is sort of ASM totic to 4.06 to
the
N divided by n times some
constant um and so uh this is it's not
going as fast as for of the N which is
any program that would actually that
would actually construct all the N AOS
would have to have to go through this
many cases uh but uh but it's still this
is this is sort of a number of ways to
combine slices and still I was even
assuming connectivity so I uh then I
found out it was very difficult to to to
uh to determine if I had one one of
these slices um uh how much how many
more uh uh uh steps it would take to
connect them all together this was the
sort of the minimum if I did it in one
in one step but these are the kind of
things I was thinking about when I when
I when I thought I had a great idea and
that was to look at diagonal slices
instead of instead of horizontal slices
so so I was going to cut through
U my nominal diagonally so now let's
take a look at this picture
here um can you zoom it zoom in on this
now this is an this is a this is a I
don't know a 70 omo or something it's
rather and it's pretty large here but it
it shows the it shows the ideas that I
had to be thinking about and I'm and I'm
showing here diagonal cuts through it
and I I'm going to try and the method
that I programmed first where I had this
world record that I thought was was was
so great uh was to go through and
construct it diagonal slice by diagonal
slice and then and then keep track of
what what diagonal slices can follow
other diagonal slices and still be
connected for example after this one I
would have the next slice would have to
have would have to have some at least
one guy connecting to this cell because
otherwise uh this guy would be isolated
and and we you know below this this part
of the diagram this has this this
picture has to has to connect it self up
somehow so so I know that there aren't
too many successes here on the next
level however I I might bring in I might
bring in some new some new people from
from the nether territories from the
left and right and put some in the
middle but anyway at minimum I need two
two more cells at the next level and and
here's one thing I could do and then I
could you know that guy could be
followed by uh by another one similarly
and then this that was maybe going this
way now here we here all of a sudden we
some some some new people come into the
here's one at the left see com coming in
and so so we can imagine but but but I
can I can imagine growing this thing by
slices and the and and the beauty of it
uh my point of view from the diagonal
slices um was that it wasn't hard to
figure out what I'd have to do below
this uh the minimum number of extra
cells I need uh to make a polyomino out
of there because uh well you see these
guys are already connected here at the
left on the right um You have to look
closely you see that this is gray and
this is gray so all I would have to do
is is is is is is connect to this guy
and to this guy so that would be one
two uh three cells with three more cells
I I can make this into a uh into a
polyomino something that's
connected um uh but if so if I was
enumerating something if I you know
suppose this is anal I don't
know I I I don't know how many cells
there are here but let's let's say that
it's it's 30 it's 27 then I could still
make 30 out of this but if but if it's
28 there's no hope you know I can
discard this and not not go any further
so um so I don't have to consider too
many slices uh uh after after a while
but anyway this is this is the idea now
now it's most this one this diagram
happens to be most interesting at at at
this point where I have quite a few
different components that are going to
have to be connected and um uh well so I
I uh so I said um but but if if I I
wanted to get a local view of it what is
the information that I need to know at a
particular diagonal slice about the top
uh that that retains all the all the
interesting
State the actual details of what goes
above that slice are unimportant all I
need to know is sort of the boundary
condition here at the slice and then I
and then um and and uh all of these
other cases will be lumped together so
this way I'll be able to uh any any
other U any any other anomal that starts
out with the same information before the
slice uh I I can consider that all uh
only once after I go this after I go
from here and uh and and so um and so uh
well the kind of information that that
you need to know is how many cells are
there um on the diagonal above it the
total number that you've had so far and
then you want to know also uh uh which
of these cells on the diagonal are
connected to to to other
ones so so my first idea was to encode
that and this this this interesting one
that I showed you uh before I I encoded
it by in this way I I uncoded that
diagonal spes
10213 okay let me let me write it down
uh larger here
um
0544 6 sub
54 and the sub 54 just meant that there
were 54 cells Al together um not on the
diagonal and and above it uh so so that
was the state of the of this of the
process up to that up to that diagonal
Point um now here's where where where we
get uh a first connection to trees U you
see the ones mean this is this is
connected component number one and and
two is connected component number two
connected component number three four
five and six there were six
six different all all the diagonals you
know this this guy number one here was
connected to this guy over here uh to
this one and this one um right but these
these uh these these uh aren't connected
to each other so I don't number exactly
which slice I've got here that would
have
a I don't it doesn't perfectly match
here
o13 maybe it's a typo 1 4
okay yeah 1 four okay that it's it it
checks out and this is four and this is
05 this is five here four four so this
this four and this four is matched to
this four now in general uh then what
this what this means is I have some I
above the diagonal these guys are
connected uh the two is connected to
something but never but that never
reaches anything else these fours are
connected and the fives are connected to
something and the sixes but but any but
this is sort of the connectivity picture
above it and um um well this looks a
little bit like a forest I mean uh uh uh
the basic principle is anyway that that
that you can't have crossover I can't
have anything where where two guys these
two guys are connected and these two
guys are
connected uh I hope you you see what why
that is this Rook wise connectivity
there's no way to to uh once I have a
pass from here to here there's no way uh
to to there no way to to to get get
through a bunch of of cells without uh
without connecting to them yourself it's
not true if you look at uh you know at
at uh at connectivity by by diagonal
neighbors there I can there I can have a
path going this way and another path
coming through this way uh and and you
can have crossover but but in the in the
polyomino case you can't have crossover
so so it has to form this hierarchical
structure this nested structure and
that's what uh that's what trees really
really represent and I counted how many
suppose I had 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 cells
on the diagonal I I said well how many
ways how many different connectivity
patterns are there uh with u uh with 10
cells in a diagonal turn out to be
exactly the number of force with 10 uh
on 10 elements um so the so U uh
uh and and uh uh I can show I can show
that uh uh uh
theistically uh in order to have a
forest what remember remember what a
forest is a forest is a is a bunch of
trees and and then a tree is um a tree
is a root plus a bunch of of children uh
and and the children form a forest so so
so the forest and trees are are kind of
the same thing a a a tree is a is a
forest with a root and a and a Forest is
a tree without a root or a bunch of
trees so so uh so now in order to
convert this into a forest uh I have to
have I have to decide who's going to be
the root let's call this a b c d e f g h
i j for example um and um and so I have
to decide who's going to be the root and
in this case I'll make I'll make sorry
the left the left guy will always be the
root so a will be the a will be the root
but but then the other people in in its
component will be it the children of a c
and
e and then uh uh in between a and C uh
I'll do the same pattern um but I but
but I I'll amp this and call these the
children of
C uh so B will be a child of c and um D
will be a child of
e and if there had been several you know
several other guys below that I I I need
a more complicated example so suppose I
have suppose I have something like this
and then I have in here another another
couple of trees uh it's getting too
complicated um so this will be this will
be good enough I'll make this a b and
then I'll have a c d in here and an E F
G H
I give you the idea an a would be the
root and then H and I would be its
children uh H however uh has three kids
uh one for this tree here which has root
B and and it's descendant e then the C
and D are considered children of E are
you with me the f f is is also another
child of H and the g is a child of so so
there's a mapping between U all these
kind of patterns and Forest uh you know
where I have uh this this part here
would also be uh would also would also
go in there f f and then um G would you
know H and I would be children of F and
then G would hook on to H so and and J
is another one so that would be a this
represent a forest of of of Three Trees
so easy way to go from between forests
and and these patterns um it was it it
it it looks easy but in fact it's it's
it's something that I didn't hadn't
really seen before because it's a funny
thing you know if you you study the way
to to Traverse a tree there's the the
two main main orders are called
pre-order and postorder in pre-order you
start with the root and then you and
then you look at the at at the children
uh uh in pre-order order and in um post
order you look you you you start with
the children first and then you do the
root last uh well in this case you're
mixing the two on even levels you do the
pre-order and on odd levels you do the
postorder so in other words first I I I
start out with with pre-order I have a
then in the in the child I I use post
order and I get B and then I and then I
you know and then I do c so if if you
actually read this in this funny order
where you switch from post order
pre-order at the same time you get AB BC
d e f g h i j it's a funny it's a funny
concept I don't know if it has any use
probably not but uh there it is um now
um uh now U so I wrote my program with
these with these slices and uh and
here's an example of what happens when
you when you uh uh confine it to um
pentomino to the case of uh of uh uh n
equal 5 can we zoom in on this a little
bit you notice I got the people here
from the computer science probably will
notice that I I got some I had some
stationary left over when I came back
from our faculty Retreat um so here's U
here what you have is you uh you can
start out at at your first slice uh you
you either have have a single single
cell on the diagonal which I call one
sub one or I have um U or I have two
cells next to each other uh one two sub
two at at on the first diagonal
everything is disconnected because the
thing about a diagonal is uh those the
different cells on the diagonal can
never be connected to each other the
other case is one
Z2 um uh and uh there's also one two
three where I have three cells in a
row and but if I do anything else uh it
would be it would be too hard to to
connect up and still have only five
cells left you I'm trying to I'm trying
to call Pinos so if I was trying to only
count Pinos I would only have four
possible starting configurations
anything else uh it's it's pretty easy
to figure out you're just looking at
something how how how how uh how to
connect it up for example here um uh in
order to connect up uh this part to this
part I'm going to need I'm going to need
a cell
here and I'm going to need a cell here
between the four and the six now in
order to now uh the fours are already
connected to each other but I got to get
the five in there somehow I have two
choices I can either connect the five to
this four which case I have to I I it
take me three steps so I'd have to i'
have to put a cell here here and here uh
or I can look to this FL which only is
one step that looks better so so I'll
put one there now in order to get the
twos with the ones I can hook this two
to this one or to this one but it's
faster to go here so I need three I need
three cells to connect that up and then
to get this three I would hook it to
this one so I need three there so so 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 nine I think nine more
cellss I can make a a polyomino out of
this and so for each for each config
configuration like this it's it's quite
easy to uh to determine the um uh the
minimum number of things to connect it
up and if that you know if that ex
exceeds the the Target that you're
shooting for 54 + 9 is is 63 if I if I
was only working for 60 ominos uh uh
this this I would throw this
out
um and uh so
so and it starts right at the very
beginning there was only four
possibilities that would get that would
get in because anything else would need
more to connect up now after I start out
with a one sub one then I have
various things that that's at the first
at the at the first diagonal then the
next slice could be another one uh but I
would have two I would have two two by
then or I could I could add another uh
uh I could I could follow this this
slice by by a one two sub three U adding
two more cells so I have three by this
time um and I I drew two arcs between
this because there are two ways to do
that I mean I if you start out with a
one um on a diagonal then um I you know
there there are two ways to put it I
could put it here or I could or I could
put it um I'm sorry uh
here so so so so these are two ways to
go from
one of you know starting with a one one
this is a 1 2 Sub three in both cases
this diagonal these are just these are
parts of different components and they
both have three cells in them so there
were two ways to go uh there and so are
that's two um that's two arcs I drew
here and I can also go from a one one of
up here to a one one sub3 that would be
if I if I took this guy and then I and
then I put uh these two cells on then I
then these would both be in the
connected to each other so it' be a one
one type of situation called 1 one sub3
so this little little graph here shows
all the possible ways there are uh to go
through uh with never getting into a
state that that that'll be bigger than
pentomino and and so uh uh if you follow
how many how many waves are there
through this diagram until the Until the
End uh uh how many roots are there
through the diagram it's 63 that's the
number of uh you know the number of
possible ways to do it and this this di
this this diagram has only 16 vertices
in it so so uh my My Hope Is that um uh
you know I'm constructing this for the
case of of of uh of Nal 30 counting 30
am in fact that's what I did and uh and
I get a a huge directed graph um and uh
one of the main pass through is going to
be 1 one 1 2 1 3 one4 and there's going
to be two to the nend ways just through
that path alone uh uh 30 ominos that
that that sort of just are sort sort of
snaky going either left or right along
along kind of a diagonal um and uh so uh
the number of pass through this diagram
is the is the thing and of course it's
really easy to calculate the number pass
through a diagram you start out and I
put a number these are little red
numbers I put underneath I put the
little red number one down here cuz
because you know there's one way to get
to there one way to get to here one way
to get to here now if I want to say how
many ways do I get to one one sub three
well
um it it can come from here or it can it
it can come two ways from there so I
take this number plus twice this number
and I get five and there's 15 ways to
get here because I had I had twice five
plus uh uh two from there and three
three times one from this
guy and uh uh so you know I got 15 and
so so so 49 of these pentomino came up
out in this node with a with a single a
single uh uh on the bottom 12 of them
came out with with two and and one each
there so so uh meanwhile I'm also
enumerating not only the the pentomino
but also the tetraminos uh because if I
look at the things uh that uh that had
that were connected but had in this
where everything has four cells it's the
case where you have all ones in there so
it be the one four and one one4 are the
two possibilities for tetral so you add
15 and four and you get 19 is the is the
number of of tetral so so this this this
little graph U gives you all the number
of nominos for n equals 1 2 3 4 and 5
and and you just go through March
through from left to right adding and
and multiplying uh and uh the total
amount of work is the number of arcs in
the in in the
graph well and and and I I count a
triple Arc I guess I only count once
because I just have to multiply by three
I don't have to actually add three
times so um uh
uh that was my uh that was the method
that I programmed and um uh it got uh it
got most interesting uh in the then in
the computer aspect of it uh as far as
how how big the graph got I had no idea
how uh you know how how many vertices I
was going to get as n gets larger and
larger but the um but the exact size of
the graph uh when n is 30 turned out be
well what would what would you guess how
many vertices do you think you know I
get 16 vertices here for five what do
you think if you get up to 30 how many
states anybody have a feeling for
it well that's okay I just asked that
because I'm stalling um but
um but I do have uh I do have the number
here and it turned out that there were 3
million of and and and and small change
vertices when uh when in is 30 it's not
not too bad uh that's only like two to
the um 2 to the 21st power um and then
um uh but but but but when I'm saying 3
million I'm counting I'm counting some
vertices the same like one one 1 2 1 3 1
4 one5 I count that as only one type of
vertex because uh the calculations that
was that I had to make was from from any
particular pattern um like one two or
one one2 3 or 11 one or 102 any pattern
like that I had to figure out what
patterns could follow it and that
calculation is the same for uh no matter
where you are in in the graph the
calculation as to what can follow a
Singleton uh is the same at this level
as at this level except that this level
has fewer arcs coming out because
because because of the cut offs some of
the things that this guy could go to are
aren't going to make pomal anymore so so
as I go to the right some of the things
coming out out uh disappear but but the
but the first time the first time a
pattern arises in the graph uh I can
calculate um all of the things that that
are going to come out of it and then um
and then I I can retire arcs for things
that are going to be so I can figure out
the lifetime of each of these patterns
so so for example the one two has a it
starts here at second round and has a
lifetime 1 two2 1 two 3 one two sub4 uh
has a lifetime uh uh from from two three
two to 3 to four and so as every pattern
that I got in this case I say there were
3 million patterns for each pattern I I
I would uh it would have a lifetime it
would be born at a certain at a certain
subscript and then it would live um and
it would lose ARS until it gets to the
to a point where finally lost loses all
its ARs and uh and uh and it dies um and
so uh so so I call these clones of of
the same vertex so this one two sub two
one two sub3 1 two sub4 they're all
clones of the vertex one two there are 3
million vertices and 8 and a half
million clones so U most of the vertices
uh only lived um only live for one cycle
and on the average they
live you know almost
three a Vertex would would would be born
and have a average lifetime of three of
of of three places in this graph um uh
and then um uh because there were 8 and
half million clones and 3 million uh
distinct vertices but the number of arcs
not counting multiplicity number of arcs
was 714
million um uh now um uh that means that
when I when I have a Vertex the first
time it has has a whole bunch of arcs
coming out of it and then then then it
lives with several generations and those
same arcs are going to come out later
but some of them will
disappear um but this is kind of an
interesting um directed graph It's Kind
it's what it's it's similar to what uh I
think Edith Cohen in her P thesis uh 10
15 years ago talked about periodic
graphs uh where where uh the graph is
sort of uh uh the the structure of the
graph locally is the same at every level
but then and then ties it ties out to to
other levels and and I had this problem
of to go through a uh a a a periodic
graph with u with vertices however uh uh
being born and dying uh and it had 714
million um arcs in it now u in my data
structure to evaluate this um I let's
see what how are we doing on time I
haven't okay yeah good um in my data
structure I I needed uh for every vertex
I had let me see where is the
where are the type deps here by the way
this is uh you know I I I I always write
in cweb and these are my my computer
programs uh that that are on the web if
you if you if you want to look for
details of this you can just download
the programs and and and see exactly
what this what this was I had to I did
program I did arithmetic here so here
vertex is 20 bytes per vertex 8 bytes
per Arc and um eight bytes per clone
eight more bytes per clone so I had um
as I said 3 million vertices so that was
60 megabytes um to store my vertex data
structures uh and then for the Clones um
uh that was you know 8 million clones
they they formed a uh well I had I
remember where those appearing with this
up so that's eight 8 and half million of
those so that's another 70 megab so or
so for the clones and then 8 Byes per
Arc well now 700 million arcs U we're
sitting here with five uh what 50 gab
no
yeah
um 5 GB of uh of memory for the arcs now
uh the program could very easily go into
thrashing and and swapping you know
running out of swap space if you if you
get that big uh um and also in order to
just send the data to the to the uh
computer
um I was sending you know I was sending
each Arc uh and so I it had to be in a
file um and I I I was able to to
compress the information for each Arc
into four bytes uh in my file but still
my file was was uh almost 3 gbt of data
uh that I had to that I had to reduce um
and that's when I found out that uh
Linux can only handle one uh 2 30 2 31
minus 1 is the largest file you can
write in Linx so I had to you know break
it into many files and read one file at
a time um it's obvious why that is
because uh well maybe they could have
gotten twice as many but but but they
don't so uh uh so so the length of a
file uh can never exceed um something
with my files were bigger than um um
well uh but but uh uh you see that
there's a recycling strategy that is
that uh when a when a a Vertex is born
it might have lots of arcs coming out of
it but then it gets older it loses these
arcs and so I I can retire the arcs as
soon as the vertex dies I don't need its
arcs anymore so I can reclaim the memory
and so it turned out I only needed 88
million working space for arcs out of
the 700 and some million and that meant
that the to my total uh uh my total
travel um needed um I think it was 750
roughly megabytes and that's that was
that fitting very nicely into the uh
computer that that the database uh guys
have here on the fourth floor so uh uh
so uh although my home computer doesn't
have that many that much memory uh uh at
the moment I'm hoping you know for
Christmas maybe I'll get more lot more
but um uh uh anyway uh uh I for bar to
Stanford and ran and ran the final
around a week ago today and I got the
and I got the answer I thought great
I've set a world record so I so and I
wrote to Portugal and I said okay well
now uh the first thing I learned on
Wednesday when I started looking at
Andrew's paper is first of all uh it
wouldn't have helped my My Method very
much but but uh he had a much he had a
better way of of coding of these these
connected components in I it and it was
Bas is another connection with trees and
so I want to show you that instead of
instead of saying one for the first
component two for the second and three
for the third and so on you can take
advantage of the fact that it's a tree
and so he encloses this with left sort
of a parenthesized structure so so the
ones uh it calls them par but the middle
one let's call it a dash
um and then the two would be I let's
just use a number one for an isolated
thing I I'll write out the code here and
then you then you get the idea uh this
will be a left parenthesis for the four
and then a dash and a right parenthesis
and the
five and I can put the zeros in here um
so I have a five letter alphabet now
um uh what what happened yeah um and
here's another one I have a felet
alphabet
um for for to to encode the diagonal
slices uh so instead of instead of
needing see I actually needed four bits
I could get up to I could get as many as
15 components uh so I needed four bits
for that uh this only needs three bits
so so I could I could have packed my
representations of all these slices uh
into a smaller number of bits in fact I
only need you know to get end bits I
only need five to the end uh it numbers
up to up to size five to the end and
sort of a base five system you see but
uh in other words uh let's let's take
another let's let's take a more
complicated U pattern where where I
might have you know this guy comes comes
down in several places and then in here
there's there's there there's two and
another one nested in here let's say and
and and and two separate guys here well
I could call this left parenthesis D-
right parenthesis and then here would be
a left right and here would be a left
right and another and sort of a one in
in the middle here and uh and these two
are separate are separate guys so so so
you see this is a this is a nice uh kind
of an algebraic notation where but where
usually when we talk about um
parenthesized formulas we we say that uh
uh well I guess John McCarthy just left
but in list notation we would only use
parentheses right um but here um U but
in here uh uh but in here actually uh uh
uh I only got you know one thing is is
sort of serving as a as a combination
sort of as a comma you know to to say
these things I could have maybe put this
call this a comma as well instead of a
dash not not a bad idea anyway uh uh
this sort of but this is is the same as
this the same as this uh uh as far as
the level in the hierarchy these guys
are connected to each other and you know
a sequence of of five things in a row
that are all connected would be would be
like that so so um uh well like I I
should have known that but um but now um
uh I I rejected working with horizontal
slices uh uh in uh because I found it
very difficult to
compute uh the the minimum number of
things to connect up a horizontal
slice if you're be if you're below a
horizontal slice um uh so so here are
for examples these cells are are um you
might have something horizontal it looks
like this and and maybe uh these guys
are connected to each other and uh and
uh these these guys are connected to
each other say and then and so on uh uh
it's it's it was quite now in order to
connect this up below it um uh on the
diagonal slices I all of my connecting
could be done between uh between the
cells but but in the if you're working
with horizontal slices you have to you
have to um you know like connect this
guy to this guy I would have to put a
cell here here here and
here um so I need four cells and then to
connect this guy to this guy also four
cells but here I'm I'm I'm uh this this
guy is doing double duty and there's
overlapping between U uh between cells
so I noticed that uh that uh to that to
find the the best way to connect up a
horizontal slice it turned out it was
very tricky because you couldn't simply
take the best way to connect up a Subs
slice and then and then assume that and
then sort of sort of uh uh uh treat this
as a unit in in in the environment uh
because you had to know more about the
details so sometimes uh you get the
optimum for the for the entire
configuration by using a non-optimum
thing in a subc configuration because of
the because because of this double duty
effect that you would have at the at the
end and so so that's why I like diagonal
slices better than horizontal slice but
that was my big mistake because I
realize
that that uh with uh with with
horizontal slices there are there are
many fewer
possible possible patterns with hor
horizontal slices uh for example in a
diagonal slice I could have shells like
this that are all
disconnected um so so so in in diagonal
slice uh I could have that either these
were either all disconnected or or or
these first two could be connected and
the second two connected or something
there was you know the number of Poss
possible forests on four cells all all
of those diagonal slices could occur in
in my pattern but in the horizontal
slice if you have four things in a row
they all have to be connected together
and every time you have every time you
go from one component to another you've
got to have a zero in between uh and
that zero is taking up precious space is
filling up precious space so it's
drastically uh every time I have
something with a large number of
components that means also I got a large
number of zeros in it and so so the
total number of of of Poss slices that
that that that have that property is
small and U and so uh so I was dealing
with my diagonal method although it was
I could do the calculations uh
unfortunately uh it didn't mean that uh
that I was actually winning uh as far as
the total size of the graph is concerned
so his graph is growing is is is growing
at a slower rate than than my graph
another thing about his
method oh um yeah another thing about
his method uh
U is that he didn't go slice by slice
but he went sell by sell in the
following way he let's suppose that
we're that we've got a a uh that we've
got a certain pattern uh let's well say
this this this um I have some pattern
here maybe this is connected to this and
and uh these these these things are are
independent now I'm going to now I'm
going to try to fill in the next row
well he fills in the next row one cell
at a time so maybe uh he you decide you
have you only only two choices whether
to put a sale here or not uh so maybe
maybe I do put a sale here now now here
uh put a sale here or not um say not put
a sale here or not say yes uh but you
can you can make these steps one at a
time and uh and and then uh it's you
it's fairly easy to uh to to update your
data SP so so you you you have some some
some huge number in of of possible
slices here uh but each n has only two
two outcomes uh uh so and you know the
the width of this is is is like n/2 uh
this is I'm trying to find little
anomals um and so I have to make n/2 of
binary choices but in in my case I was
dealing with a huge number of slices
followed by a huge number of slices so I
was sort of saying every slice n is
followed by n others and so I so I was
considering sort of n s uh uh uh
operations well he's doing sort of like
uh capital N time little n operations to
get from one to the next on the other
hand it's not clear that he's winning
because when I'm going from one slice to
another I'm actually
jumping not not from from this row to
the next row but I sometimes you know I
I can jump from one row
to uh several steps ahead of time so I'm
not you know it's not clear uh about the
trade-off but but anyway his method was
quite different from mine although it
did have the same idea of of of at some
some points in the in the process you
you you you you have uh all of the
nominal that have a certain boundary
pattern at the bottom and that's your
that's the state of your of your process
um so um uh those were the the main the
main things about about Andrew's method
um now um
I want to mention one other thing
quickly that still might be interesting
about my method from a from a
theoretical point of view and uh
so namely if for each for each pattern
um uh forget about the col forget about
the Clones now let's suppose that I was
doing infinite aminos and I was going to
was going to look at this the infinite
set of all directed graphs that that uh
that that that can occur you know for
for as many possible so I want to get
the generating function um for polyomino
of Z + 2 z^2 5 Z Cub sorry this is um uh
these are pomal that have that have a
single uh that start out with pattern
one uh that start out the first diagonal
has a single cell on it U and and and
then there's for each pattern uh like my
102 patterns these would be all
polyomino that start out with a with a
particular
uh partial patterns that that are built
on them so I can I can think of this
infinite sequence of uh G sub Alpha
being a uh uh for for every for every uh
slice pattern every diagonal slice
pattern Alpha I can get a complex uh uh
function G sub Alpha U that actually has
satisfies a very simple set set of
linear equations uh namely U uh uh G sub
Alpha is the is z to the m it's the m is
the number of slices the cells in in
slic alpha or number of nonzeros and
then Delta Alpha says that there's only
one component or not and then C Alpha
Beta is the is the number of ways to go
between slice Alpha and slice beta and
this uh this system of this infinite
system of linear equations connects
these complex uh functions uh and it and
I and it might be that this system of of
linear equations is sort is sort of U
diagonally dominant you know that
there's some way to say that that we can
that we can uh use uh uh
uh the proper uh uh hver space
techniques to to uh uh to to figure out
the U the IG the the dominant IG value
of this of this system and uh uh by by
by by calculation and get rigorous
bounds uh and and so I I I wrote this
letter to uh uh Professor de bruy uh
last week uh asking for his help in this
and see if he can figure out the the uh
uh the thing because uh um uh the it
turns out that the that the um uh the uh
the latest report from um Australia that
I got from uh uh professor Gutman uh
yesterday
or in some letters that I've had with
them saying that this uh uh the number
of of of polyaminals seems to be growing
as C * Theta to the N / n * 1
+ uh D1 Over N plus D2 Over N the 3
haves plus D3 n n squ and so on um
empirically uh it looks like it's having
this form of of growth which is much
different than the earlier conjectures
which which we're putting an end to the
three 78 here or something but the fact
that it's is looking like this
empirically uh is good news from the
point of view that probably uh uh
there's going to be some mathematical uh
uh uh way to actually figure out what
this constant Theta is here it's it's it
seems empirically to be 4.06 uh uh two
something or other I think we' got about
five more places here uh some of you
came to my earlier this year where I
calculated a constant to 40 decimals uh
I'll never know this constant in my
lifetime to uh to more than than seven
or eight decimals I'm sure and this is
only empirical nobody's even ever proved
rigorously that this constant is less
than 4.6 or more than
3.92 but empirically it seems that we
that we can get a pretty good guess at
it but the but the the data looks like
this it looks like there's going to be a
a a a radius of 1 over Thea will be the
radius of convergence of of all of these
uh of all these these generating
functions these sub Alpha as functions
of complex M and so there's some hope
for for a mathematical attack on it
based on this diagonal slices because
the diagonal slices have a have much
simpler properties than the horizontal
slice computationally however the
horizontal slices are winning and now I
got the last few minutes I wanted to
tell you oops I want to tell you why is
it that um they were able to go up to 46
inste uh after after all so that's what
I learned about last Thursday and uh and
I've been programming all weekend um uh
the method um I figured out a way to to
determine how how to how to connect up
any pattern of of um of horizontal
slices and it's a very
complicated very complicated algorithm I
don't but but but it's very it was key
to to this new method that they have and
so their new method is sort of combining
one of the things that I had in my diag
SES with Andrews idea of horizontal fles
um and um uh but the
uh I don't have time to go into the
details but it turned out that that I I
was able to use the the theory of Min
plus arithmetic um in in Matrix U uh the
normal M the normal idea of of of matrix
product is that C J is the sum of over K
of a i k b
KJ can't read that but instead I'm
taking CI J is equal to the minimum over
K of a i k plus b KJ and this is this
this is uh uh this Min plus Matrix
arithmetic actually arises when you're
studying shortest path problems and and
other problems and it's it's has lots of
nice properties similar to ordinary
matrix multiplication uh and using this
on 2x2 matrices that uh it wasn't too
hard to figure out the the connectivity
problem the minimum number of cells to
connect up a a a given horizontal slice
with a given Force pattern um over there
now
um uh the new method uh uh is is
uh is based on the following rather
simple idea instead of just enumerating
nominos uh that
are that that you can sort of figure out
that the maximum width you need is n
over2 here and then and then uh and's
method would would would go through and
figure out all anomals by by they're
coming down uh uh slice by slice in this
horizontal way uh instead they they will
actually say that they'll take a certain
bounding rectangle certain height and
certain width and and they and they they
insist that the that the that this be
that the that the anomal span this
rectangle means that it has to it has to
occupy some cells on all on all four
boundaries so so that H and W are the
minimum height and width that will
contain the anomo and and so you so you
figure out that there aren't too many
values of H and W that you need uh for
to get all anomos because the the skinny
ones are are are the ones that are
skinny in the vertical Direction have
are the same as the ones in the
horizontal Direction so you don't need
too many HW and if you do that then you
then you use Andre scheme uh uh but but
uh but you but you cut off as soon as
you get to a a slice that's not going to
be able to to fit it's not going to fill
all the way to the bottom it's can take
too many it's going to take too many
cells to to to fill and so
uh so this this drastically limits the
number of of possible States slices that
you have to consider and that means that
uh again uh we we can get it down even
though we're going up to Nal 46 instead
of Nal 30 we're still in the 1 gigabyte
memory range one more one more uh thing
that Andrew uh uh had in his program
that I that I should have known and it's
I'm kicking myself for not knowing about
it in U I needed eight bytes for
every uh in my you know for all of my AR
for all my uh U data here I
needed I mean for all of my clones I
needed 8 bites because I was keeping a
64bit counter of of the counts um you
know go go through I have to count for
each for each vertex I have to count how
many paths there were to get to that
vertex and these numbers are getting
huge so I needed 64 bit uh uh for this
and so so so I had U I had these eight 8
and a half million counters um but uh
but hrew pointed out you don't need you
don't need to to do that you you um uh
you you can just do it like with one
bite counters and then run the program
uh several times uh but you calculate
modulo different
primes and then you can reconstruct the
answers afterward right so so now that
was that was in my book you know but but
I didn't you
know but you know but I always thought
that was only for parallel computers you
know I I always thought okay you have
all these different parallel computers
and one of them is doing it mod P1 one's
mod P2 and so on then you know then we
get but here I only I only have one
computer so so I I I flushed that idea
out of my head but you know I got plenty
of time to do this uh it took me 13
hours to generate the data but once I
got the data I could run it through in
half an hour uh to figure out all the
counts so I could I so I I had a chance
to you know I could I could go through
10 times uh these counts with different
times and then reconstruct the answers
afterward and save a lot of memory that
way so that's that saves a lot in fact
with one bite with only with eight bytes
uh uh you can you know you can actually
calculate numbers up to uh 10 to the
109th uh uh
you can you know first mod two to the
eth then mod three to
the fifth and then Mod Five you know you
you can get enough relatively prime
cases so that U so that it turns out
that that that uh uh even even doing on
an 8bit uh uh computer you can do it
actually the 16 bits of course would
save a factor to if you have it depends
on how much memory you have so uh um uh
now um uh uh if you're interested in
this watch my uh website the next few
days and see if I and see if I get to my
program working uh I hope I get the same
answers that they did in Australia
otherwise it'll be really interesting
we'll have to figure out if their
algorithm for for this bounding process
is correct or mine is with my Min plus
arithmetic or what um and I have a few
more um tricks up my sleeve where I
think I can save a c a factor of four in
the method that that they use so I might
be able to get up to 47
uh and certainly um they wrote in
Fortran and I'm writing in cweb so I
have to be way ahead
there
and now okay any I I I guess I run over
a bit though so any
questions
yeah you
can more than gab please use LC
64 what yeah SE 64
L LC
64 okay Tak
a I see I I see to a SE and a file but
how does but it doesn't show up by by LS
just listing a
f just I I see and then it will okay
thank
you
okay yes um I'm just wondering is there
similar problem in 3D
yes in fact
uh in three dimensions now here for
example these are threedimensional but
they but they turn out that the ones
that this comes from a set of 12 which
are only the two dimensional cases but
how many you know how many uh U I forget
the exact number of of ways to put five
cubes together some of them go out
outside a plane um and um uh in fact uh
now now this constant
4.02 uh 4.06 uh
so on this data here uh this uh I
decided uh that in my in volume four I'm
going to call this clarner constant um
uh after David clarner who uh was the
first to prove that it exists that that
there is a you know that that grows that
the that the um that the nth rot of of
tben uh approaches are constant and and
uh and David clarner proved in the in
the 60s that that this constant exists
he spent much of his lifetime uh
analyzing this and getting the best
bounds on on the constant and he died a
couple years ago uh he was a professor
at Stanford for in the early 70s for for
a few years and uh and and this was a
thing of very great interest to him and
I just checked with the physicists in uh
Australia and they they agree with me
that we should call it carnis constant
henceforth um and feta was his his his
notation for it too so now the uh the
physicists are going to adopt this I'm
glad to glad to say well anyway the
reason I'm saying this is because Ker's
father ker got this this idea from his
father who was fascinated by these cubes
and there was a big controversy as to
how many I think it was where are there
to put six cubes together and uh and uh
the and people had said there were
1,24 you know two to the 10th and it
sounded like such a great number but
cler's father built a set of them and
had,
123 you know and and they they had a
good uh you know they had a very good uh
uh uh uh woodworking shop in their in
their house and uh and uh and and his
David's father was right uh so so the
fact so so so the the the
threedimensional problem is also very
very close to David's heart and and so
on now the uh U these these methods
though U are are a lot slower because we
we can't slice the three-dimensional
ways we have lot more safe to keep track
of um so so the threedimensional case
looks hard on the other hand the N
dimensional case nomino in space is is
Trivial it's the it's exactly the same
number as as as trees threee trees um in
the graph theoretical sense of of of of
you know so so it turns out that there
you know it's pretty easy to map every
possible every possible graph that has
no Cycles into into a into an N
dimensional anomo or n minus one
dimensional nomino um and uh so so uh
reminds me of another thing uh that is
that some of some um some some some
planer polyomino are also trees in the
sense that between any two cells there's
only one path from one cell to another
you know you look at the pental and and
some of
them are are are trees this is a tree uh
while while while while the p pental is
not a tree because to get from here to
here you can go either to this way or
this way so so so uh you can uh the the
the nice thing about the Andrew's method
and this new method that I got from from
his uh successors in in Australia uh uh
gives you the number of of tree
polyaminals uh almost for free because
it's a subset of the number of slice
movements that you can make uh so so so
the same graph uh I I could do this with
my diagonal slices too I could just I
could just cut out a few of the arcs
here where where where I'm uh where
where I'm making a cycle and I have I
have the trees oh the Tre the Tre case
so yeah the the end dimensional case is
is quite uh is quite interesting but uh
three dimensions looks real
hard to do this hierarchic you want to
compute an in know you ask how many ways
can I put an in
half yeah I'm glad you asked that the
question is what about building at lar
so on Thursday morning
I I had this this I had I have to say
that when I saw the web page and looked
at it Thursday morning and I found out
that they had numbers that went up to
46 uh and I checked the case of 29 and
30 and I had the same answers as they
did U it I it was the I I I think it was
the greatest surprise I ever had in my
whole life you know never was I so
shocked to to real to to know that that
somebody had been able to go that much
farther um and so I so as I'm swimming
that morning you know I'm figuring how
did they possibly do it you know this
happens you know somebody solves a a
problem that you didn't know the
solution but you but all you know is
that the existence of the solution they
have a way to do it how do they do it
and so you figure and then you say oh of
course they did this you know and so
sometimes that's a good way to do
research if somebody if if if you know
somebody comes to you and said they've
just proved the remon hypothesis and
then you say oh of course why didn't I
think of that you
know and so and and so as I'm going to
swim on Thursday morning you know I'm
just knowing that existence of their
result I'm saying oh of course they took
n over two they you know they took 23
omos and put them together and and made
46 am out of them you know um and uh uh
and and but by the time I was finished
with the swim I realized that that
doesn't work because the because still
the number the amount of data was was
still growing at up to size 23 well well
I get the 23 omino I only had to go up
to size 23 over2 so so um um so I I was
I was mistified and I and I went to the
library I thought I would find out the U
uh you know I would find out the the
they announced it in the Journal of
physics earlier this year and and I
looked at the article and it said it
just had a reference and the method we
used was Journal statistical physics to
appear and and it hadn't appeared yet uh
but then but then I found it on the U on
the LA on the on archive server at Los
elos I found comp of the paper which
told me their method in that and their
method of going by by by height and
width was was the was the Clincher so
this means that when you when you're
doing 46 case you have to consider a 23x
23 uh but but there are very few 23x 23s
that that would that were worth that
that because in order to get in order to
to to get all the way uh to to either
sides uh it takes 45 it takes 45 guys in
there so there are very few 46 omino
that'll fit in 23x 23 and you don't need
a 23x 24 or 20 you know but but this U
well no sorry 23x 24 you also need um
but but but so so uh the the fundamental
problem was as far as I know is is uh uh
you can't stick two of them together
without a lot of you know without keep
keeping a lot of structure as to which
things you occupy and which you aren't
uh but if you if but if you do this this
width height then then uh uh you can you
can weed out all kinds of unproductive
cases as you're going and and so so you
solve it as separate separate things for
all all relevant W and a and this is the
this is the key that brought it way down
uh the method ander's method was sare of
3 to the N uh and their method is
looking like
2.1 to the N or something like that
empirically um uh sorry n over two so
1.4 to the N you know um it say
1.73 so so so um
uh that's the trick that seems that
seems to have worked now I uh one of my
tricks that I'm going to use that I hope
to since this means that I should be
able to go two more steps if I can see
the factor two with the same memory now
and I know that their computer had only
one gigabyte of memory um they've got a
8 gab memory machine on order but they
don't have it yet so so I'm still
working on on equal on equal footing
with them and so one of my ideas is in
this box I'm I'm going to insist that
it's I'm going to save a factor to by by
insisting that it's sort of be be
heavier to the to the right there's
symmetry between left and right so if I
get to a configuration where there's
more cells on the left I can flip it
over um uh so I can save a factor
through there now there's another
symmetry between top and bottom I could
insist that it's that that there that
there's more more than half of them
occur in the top half of this diagram I
don't know if that that program seems
really very hard to write so I'm not
going to write that but but anyone in
the audience wants to do that um then
you can set another record save another
Factor two go up you you know take my
program and general now another thing
that there's the case of holes in um uh
when you get up as far as Nal
7 you you you you reach uh seven aminal
that look like
this uh but there's a hole in the middle
of um and
so uh some people say well this you know
this isn't really nice we we we like we
like the the U the white space to be
connected as well as the black space uh
and so um and so this is called a holy p
pentomino and then there's the
Unholy um case which uh and and and go
calls them profane po anyway the case
the poly is without holes now now you
can actually you could actually take
take my program and I'm not going to
have time to do this so if any of you
wants to wants to do this after I put it
up on the web next week U you can you
you can you can enumerate the um the
Unholy pentomino two by by classifying
the zeros uh by keeping track of which
of these zeros is connected to the
outside and which of these zeros is is
connected to each other so so you know
like like this zero is connected to this
one maybe this one is going to be
connected to this one maybe these two
guys will be connected to the outside
and this this zero will be independent
but so so that's part of the state
knowing how the zeros are connected and
then just make sure that you don't lose
it uh uh lose some zeros inside uh and
so then you could then you could count
the number of U Unholy pentomino uh uh
much higher than has ever been done I
think the record so far is only n equals
24 or something like that so so so
that'll be a an 8bit code instead of a
five bit code I mean eight8 character
code instead of a five character
alphabet um uh and so it fits still in
three bits and it's uh it it would be a
small extension of the program that I'm
going to write to to actually uh uh to
actually count them I'm not going to
have time to do
it so um uh there's lots
of the growth constant looks like like
the same but but uh the program would
only run about twice as
long to have example picture of one
solution example picture of what one
solution one solution I mean the only
picture I have is this one that I made
but this is not this is but there's a
sort of a general question as to what's
the what does a random one look like you
know is it sort of sparse like this or
is it or you know if I if I if I you
know there's there's these resillience
of of of 30 omino but if I if I look at
uh if I look at 10 of them are they
mostly going to be Bunchy or or spread
out you know uh that I don't know there
is a but they have calculated the radius
of gation of these things uh uh so sort
of know something about the center of
GRA so so that that it tells a little
bit about it but uh but I still haven't
got a good intuition for
it Generate random can I use my program
to do Generate random ones generate a
random one um well uh given these counts
I can do it I mean uh you
know you if you have if I if I know what
the what the um what what what what the
numbers are how many paths do to we
place and it's easy to uh uh go backward
uh so so in other words I you know I
would choose with probability 49 6 FS to
start here and then and then I then I
know uh which way to go back and so yeah
so you could make a uniform thing given
all this data which I had all WIS
counter was sitting there u in in the
computer so I could generate a random
one
yeah well
yeah convenient ways to eliminate
rotations and Reflections uh now
rotations and Reflections that actually
make it easier to count because uh if
you have uh for example if I want to
count how many how many polyomino uh
have a horiz have a horizontal
reflection then um then I then every
time I place down one cell I place down
another one in horizontally uh opposite
place and so it it and so so uh uh I
could I could sort of enumerate the the
60 ominos with a horizontal reflection
in about this time that it would take me
to do the 30 omos and so so in order to
figure out how many 30 ominos have
horizontal reflection it's you know you
know I can do all the 15 ninal in in
half a second and so and so so that's
very you know and and and uh now hor now
now from the DI by diagonal slices uh uh
actually
uh um I get for free the diagonal the
case of diagonal symmetrical ones uh I I
can look at this uh I I can look at this
diagram and tell you how many how many
pinals have a DI are symmetrical about
the diagonal from these numbers but the
uh but the other kind of like a 90°
rotation and things like that um uh it's
it's it's e easier to use another method
but these these what what but the total
number of um the total number of
distinct ones like this 12 you is equal
to 1/8 * 63 which is the you know the
number I counted here plus uh the number
of of of pentomino that have a um uh uh
that have a horizontal uh uh reflection
I I can't remember what this number is
you know um uh plus plus the number that
have a vertical plus the number that
have a 90° this way plus the number that
have 180 Plus plus the number that have
a through 70 and then there's the
diagonal so so so there are eight there
are eight different um symmetries of a
square of of the plane of and and and
and you enumerate um the kind that have
that have no you you know that have that
have no symmetry that have that have
each one of these eight and then you add
that together divide by eight that's
burn size lemon that gives you the the
number of of distinct shapes um and and
and what I'm saying is this number these
numbers are all much easier to calculate
than the first
number like the running time is like the
square root of the running time to
calculate the first number so so so by
calculating the first number then then
to figure out the the other the other
number is going to it's another it's
another computer program but uh the
running time is is going to be is going
to be easy needs to be done though
uh
okay well Merry Christmas to
all